never on the conjuring was like the
savior of horror movies is like this
thing like you've reinvigorated people's
love for horror movies kind of now the
director of this movie's gonna direct
the conjuring three so the course of La
Llorona it's a horror movie it's a new
one it's actually tied to another horror
movie franchise I didn't know it was
before I watched this it's not even
important to the plot for some nice
little Easter egg I'll give you a second
to guess which one it's like the only
horror movies that come out these days
that's not a spoiler really this is the
movie this one and so now this is a
horror movie you know how it's gonna go
because they all go there they're all
the same [ __ ] a spirit gets unleashed
now the spirits gonna terrorize his
family and the end of the movie they're
gonna seek help and they're gonna try to
get the spirit out of the house and save
the family it's all the same thing it
all happens the same as little
differences and motivation of the spirit
as long ago she drowned these kids and
now she wants to drown kids I mean
parent is a single mom of two who works
for CPS so the job of the parents a
little different the motivation of the
spirits a little different but in the
end it's all the same [ __ ] it goes down
like any other horror movie I'll give
this movie this a couple times like oh
the imageries that was kind of cool
imagery a couple of times I mean it's
not like it's an abundance of great
imagery a couple times I was just
surprised because the rest of the time
it's really predictable stuff like
there's a door slowly creaking open the
door has a mirror on it and as its
opening up it's you could see the
reflection of the room and of course
you're like oh llama gasps mmm ghost was
gonna be in the mirror uh-huh this is
another case of a horror movie that was
built around the moments they could do
not actually the movie there's someone
sat down like all right horror movie
wise it'd be neat if a little girl opens
an umbrella and she sees the ghost if
she lifts up this see-through umbrella
and the ghost isn't there and she puts
it back and stare and it's like all
right let's make a movie around moments
like that so the scary moments are
really what built this movie not the
characters not the plot not anything you
can really latch on to it built some
cliches [ __ ] around those moments and
also the movies really boring it's just
boring there was nothing pulling me into
it it was just another all right I've
seen this a hundred times before they're
all this
[ __ ] and so now we just boards me it's
superhero fatigue gonna happen I don't
know but horror movie fatigue has
happened twice since I've been on
YouTube twice like people got sick of
horror movies in 2012 at the conjuring
and sinister people were like oh maybe
they're cool again I think it was 2012
was that 13 actually might've been 13 oh
wow that time people like hey their knee
and now it's like nope they suck again
two distinct moments of horror movie
fatigue yeah I just I'm there I'm there
now movie also has a couple of moments
of humor which I generally like the fact
that humor is interjected in movies like
this if it works but this was like
nothing else was there and then a couple
times there's just these humorous
moments where it was like they watched
the movie and there were our least
watched what they had up until those
points they were like hmm
for the next couple shots let's have
humor does it clash with everything else
totally speaking in the movie yeah but
we're gonna have a couple of jokes I
heard people like jokes and I heard if
they're jokes and movies it actually
slows down the fatigue of the franchise
and people in this movie are stupid it's
almost a given like it's it in and of
itself as a cliche for haunting movies
to have stupid people but this thing
that happens in here I kind of want to
talk about it I don't think it is
whatever I want to talk about it I
genuinely maybe spoiler spoiler there
question mark there's this scene where
they're trying to get the ghosts to
spirit out of the house and then when
the spirit gets out of the house they're
gonna make a barrier and on the front
door and be like hi you can't get it now
huh fooled you then they get the spirit
out and it's like oh the back door and
they run to the back - no it's gonna get
in the back door like that caught you
off-guard like where do they like oh
yeah the back door this house has one of
those crazy yeah when you try a funnel
or bottleneck your spirit out of the
only entrance or exit make sure that's
the only entrance and or exit and odds
are gonna take a shot in the dark it
probably has a backdoor this movie isn't
the biggest piece of [ __ ] I've ever seen
or anything like that it's just been
here done that a few times it's not just
like I've been here done those once
there's nothing engaging in the movie
there's nothing really holding me there
to say I'm not gonna remember this movie
in t-minus one day yep already forgot
like actually I'm pretty sure I forgot
most of it by now I'm not bullshitting
you I think I did well the curse of
your own now have you seen it white did
you think about it or what's a horror
movie that actually does break the mold
that's actually good maybe I didn't hear
about what is it whatever you think
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
[Music]